YOU DON’T FIRE PEOPLE TO
IMPROVE YOUR ECONOMY.
>> Harris: STEVE FORBES
CHAIRMAN AND EDITOR IN CHIEF OF
FORBES MEDIA AND FORMER
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE IS IN
FOCUS NOW.
STEVE, THIS FEELS LIKE WE’RE
RUNNING AROUND IN CIRCLES.
WHAT IS THE PRESIDENT TRYING TO
DO?
>> THE PRESIDENT IS TRYING TO
HAVE IT ALL WAYS.
HIS WHOLE THING ON VACCINES IS
VERY CONFUSING.
PEOPLE DON’T LIKE THE COERCION
PART OF IT.
IT IS LEADING TO PEOPLE GETTING
FIRED.
HERE WE HAVE HEALTH WORKERS
BEING LAID OFF AT A TIME WHEN
THERE IS A SHORTAGE.
AIRLINES SAME THING.
SO THE DELTA VARIANT HURT IN
SEPTEMBER AND THIS VACCINE
MANDATE IS ALSO GOING TO HURT.
WHAT COMES OUT OF THIS JOBS
REPORT IS WHAT’S AMAZING IS HOW
THE ECONOMY IS  READY TO GO IF
THESE BARRIERS ARE REMOVED.
IF YOU LOOK AT HITTING WHAT
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE DOING.
JOB CREATION WAS 526,000.
THE BIG DECLINE CAME NOT IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR UP OVER 300,000
IN SEPTEMBER, REALIZED ANOTHER
100,000 FOR JULY AND AUGUST.
THE BIG FALL-OFF WAS IN
GOVERNMENT WORKERS.
ESPECIALLY IN THE SCHOOLS.
PEOPLE CONFUSED ABOUT WHAT THEY
CAN AND CAN’T DO.
GOVERNMENT INFLICTED REPORT NOT
SOMETHING ABOUT THE NATURAL
HEALTH OF THE ECONOMY, WHICH
WOULD HEAL QUICKLY IF CERTAIN
THINGS WERE NOT STUPIDLY DONE
TO BE BLUNT ABOUT IT.
>> Harris: THAT IS SO
FASCINATING.
SO WHAT YOU ARE SAYING IS
PRESIDENT BIDEN EFFECTIVELY IS
GETTING HIS OWN WORKFORCE FIRED.
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT HE
CAN CONTROL IN THE GOVERNMENT,
RIGHT?
>> YES.
>> Harris: MIND-BOGGLING.
HUGE COMPANIES LIKE IBM AND
AMERICAN AIRLINES ARE NOW
ALREADY WARNING THEIR EMPLOYEES
THAT IF THEY ARE NOT VACCINATED
BY NOVEMBER 24th THAT’S THEIR
DEADLINE, THEY WILL BE FIRED.
IBM --
>> THEY DON’T TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
PEOPLE WHO HAVE HAD THE DISEASE
WHERE IMMUNITY IS BETTER THAN
THE VACCINES.
THIS IS VERY DESTRUCTIVE
ULTIMATELY.
>> Harris: I LOOKED IT UP.
IBM IS THE SEVENTH LARGEST
COMPANY IN THE NATION.
THEY HIRE A WHOLE LOT OF FOLKS.
WE KNOW THAT SMALL BUSINESSES
HIRE UPWARDS OF 66% OF THE
AMERICAN WORKFORCE.
THEY HAVE TO HIRE LITERALLY
THEIR OWN VACCINE CZAR TO
FIGURE OUT WHO IS VACCINATED
AND WHO IS NOT FOR THEIR
CUSTOMER BASE LIKE IN NEW YORK
AND ALSO THEIR EMPLOYEES.
WHAT IS THIS GOING TO DO TO THE
PRICE OF THINGS?
>> WHAT IT DOES IS ARTIFICIALLY
RAISE COSTS.
WE HAVE COSTS RISING BECAUSE
THE FED IS PRINTING TOO MUCH
MONEY WHICH WILL AVALANCHE THE
ECONOMY NEXT YEAR WHICH THEY’LL
STOP THE GIMMICKS NEXT YEAR.
THEY ARTIFICIALLY -- THE WHOLE
THING AND THE BREAKDOWN OF THE
SUPPLY CHAIN FROM COVID.
ECONOMISTS AND EXPERTS UNDER
ESTIMATES WHEN YOU SHUT DOWN
THE GLOBAL ECONOMY.
YOU DON’T TURN IT ON LIKE A
LIGHT SWITCH.
THEY KEEP ADDING THE ARTIFICIAL
BARRIERS THAT STAND IN THE WAY,
RAISE COSTS AND THAT IS GOING
TO HIT THE CONSUMER WHICH WILL
HIT THE ECONOMY.
CONNECT THE DOTS, HELLO.
>> Harris: IT SEEMS SO BASIC
AND OF COURSE YOU ARE SO GREAT
AT EXPLAINING THINGS IT MAKES
YOU EVEN UNDERSTAND IT TO THE
POINT LIKE YOU WANT TO CALL THE
WHITE HOUSE AND SAY WHAT DON’T
YOU GET?
BUT WE CAN’T DO THAT.
>> WE CAN TRY AND THEY’LL SEND
THE F.B.I. ON US.
>> Harris: ONLY BECAUSE WE’RE
PARENTS.
DEMOCRATS ARE NO CLOSER TO A
DEAL ON THE SPENDING BILL AND
BIDEN HIS WHOLE AGENDA IN PERIL
NOW.
PROGRESSIVES SAYING THEY ARE
WILLING TO NEGOTIATE BUT THEY
WANT A HIGHER PRICE TAG THAN
SOME MODERATES, A LOT HIGHER.
ONE OF THE HOLD-OUTS IS ARIZONA
SENATOR KYRSTEN SINEMA.
WE’VE SEEN HER HARASSED ALL
OVER THE PLACE.
IT HAPPENED AGAIN.
>> CONGRESSWOMAN?
>> SENATOR.
>> SENATOR SINEMA, WOULD YOU
PLEASE TELL THE MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS WHO SUPPORT BUILD
BACK BETTER WHY YOU WON’T VOTE
FOR IT?
WHO ARE YOU GOING TO LEAVE
BEHIND?
SENIORS WHO NEED HEALTHCARE,
FOLKS WHO NEED HOUSING, THE
CLIMATE CRISIS?
WHO ARE YOU GOING TO LEAVE
BEHIND, SENATOR?
>> Harris: SHE DID CORRECT HER
TITLE.
SHE EARNED IT.
SHE IS A SENATOR, STEVE.
>> YES, SHE IS A SENATOR AND SO
FAR A VERY COURAGEOUS ONE UNDER
INTENSE PRESSURE.
WHAT SEE AND SENATOR MANCHIN
RECOGNIZE IT IS NOT JUST THE
TOP LINE NUMBER.
YOU CAN MANIPULATE THAT AND
TAKE IN 10 YEARS OF TAX
REVENUES AND ONLY HAVE FIVE
YEARS OF SPENDING SAYING
EVERYTHING WILL EX SPIRE 3 TO 5
YEARS AND WHAT IS YOUR PROBLEM.
THEY ARE TRY TO FOB OFF COSTS
ON PAPER TO THE STATES TO MAKE
THE NUMBER LOOK LOWER.
MASSIVE NEW ENTITLEMENTS THAT
YOU NEVER GET RID OF AND
UNDERMINE AMERICAN ECONOMY AND
LEAVE BEHIND MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
WHO WANT TO IMPROVE THEIR LOT
IN LIFE BECAUSE THERE WILL BE
LESS OPPORTUNITY.
SO THIS BILL WILL HARM AND
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE THE WHOLE
AMERICAN HE CAN AND SOCIAL
SYSTEM AND VERY LITTLE DEBATE
ON IT.
YOU WANT FREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
WHY ARE COLLEGE COSTS GOING UP
HIGHER THAN THE RATE OF
INFLATION?
ADMINISTRATIVE BLOAT.
WHY DON’T THEY ADDRESS THAT?
THESE ARE ALL ISSUES THAT
DESERVE DEBATE AND DISCUSSION
INSTEAD OF TRYING TO RAM IT
THROUGH IN A GRAND BILL THAT
TURNS AMERICA UPSIDE DOWN AND
WE AREN’T SUPPOSED TO SAY
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
THE POLICE POWERS FOR THE IRS
ARE NOW OMINOUS.
EVERYTHING YOU DO WILL BE NOW
IN THE PURVIEW OF I.R.S. AGENTS.
>> Harris: THAT’S TRUE.
IF THE D.O.J. SICS THE F.B.I.
ON PARENTS IT’S TWO LANES OF --
THE F.B.I. AND I.R.S..
YOU SAID SOMETHING THAT WAS SO
TRUE AND SO JARRING I WANT TO
MAKE SURE PEOPLE GET IT ON OUR
WAY OUT, STEVE.
THAT IS THAT ENTITLEMENTS
ROLLED INTO A HUGE BILL LIKE
THIS YOU NEVER GET RID OF THEM
BECAUSE NO MATTER WHAT YOU DO,
YOU DON’T LINE -- RED LINE THEM
AN EXECUTIVE ORDER.
NOBODY GOES -- NOBODY GOES
THROUGH AND SAYS YOU KNOW WHAT?
ON PAGE 2,550 LET’S RED LINE
THAT ENTITLEMENT.